[Applause]
mickey
james is a six-time wwe women's champion
her husband is the current nwa champion
and mickey also has one incredible voice
she just released a new song with chapel
heart
tractors on the dirt road
[Music]
mickey james welcome back to the show i
love
this new song of yours uh it could be an
anthem for the summer i would say
grown grown sleep woman it's a great
song it's a fantastic song
thank you the gosh song it's you know
song
the gosh song that's really powerful i
think it's powerful like the song
i'm really i've been so excited about
all the feedback from it it's just been
amazing because like even in the studio
and it all coming together i felt so
great about it i was like oh this is
going to be great and i just think that
it's really going to empower so many
people it could be like the
anthem of the summer and so we'll see
how did the pairing with chapel heart
come together how did you guys pair up
with the song
um well that was through my friend sean
gassaway who also is a writer on the
song because we had kind of started to
work on this song and then
he introduced me to them and i actually
was in their music video you could have
jolene and made a little special
appearance
[Music]
i met them through shawn and we sat down
and really
you know really fleshed out this song
and really tried to
speak volumes and speak volumes for
women and like just like
breaking down barriers and just
everything you know
that we love about being powerful women
and you know
with a little sass yeah so how old is
your son now
um he'll be seven in september so he's
six he just graduated kindergarten
oh yeah does he what just does he have
your your action figure and your
husband's action figure and does he
does he think that most mom and dads
have their own action figures
he does have our action figures and it's
like but
i don't really think he has any like
any idea of what we do or who like he's
seen
it and he's watched it he's gone to the
shows and he's been there but it's not
it's like it just really doesn't faze
him and maybe it's just because it's so
normal for him so he doesn't understand
how different it is from everybody else
you know it's just
it's like oh yeah that's just the thing
they do mommy don't daddy no that's what
he calls him
oh does he really yeah does he go to his
friend's house i'm like hey where's your
where's your mom and dad's action
figures oh they don't happen
yeah no no well we love it i mean you're
killing it you're crushing it and the
song is fantastic
it's going to be an anthem this summer
you can get mickey's new song on all
streaming platforms in las vegas now
will be